James Harden and Russell Westbrook
they've been inextricably linked since
their time together on the OKC Thunder
over 10 years ago they are two of the
most influential defining players of
their generation a pair that go down as
two of the most statistically productive
guards of all time and who split
opinions as harshly as anything
everything about them is a point of
contention everyone has an opinion about
them Westbrook and Harden are both
supremely gifted and maddeningly flawed
their places in the discuss of alltime
greats will be argued over forever but
how do they compare to each other I
guess the logical place to start is to
just talk about their style how they
played basketball I don't know how you
compare Prime Westbrook to anybody in
this category he was a freak a tidal
wave of force intensity and energy he
was the most gifted athletic specimen
the position of point guard has ever
seen and used every inch and ounce of
his body to its absolute limit
unsurprisingly he goes down as probably
the best rebounding guard ever and a
nightmarish Coast to Coast threat
Westbrook could attack the glass like a
forward run the floor like a
thoroughbred and attack the basket as if
it owed him money watching him play was
like seeing a toddler on a sugar high if
that toddler had a 40-in vertical and
the acceleration of a dragster but he
never crashed he played harder than just
about everyone around him and still
managed to never slow down in that way
he shared the same pack mode mentality
as guys like Allan Iverson and a young
Kobe Bryant an attitude that said I am
going to outwork you I will never slow
down and you will not be able to keep up
unfortunately that mentality didn't
always work in his favor just like
Iverson and just like Kobe Westbrook has
been criticized for his famously
undisciplined shot selection he refuses
to stop shooting despite being perhaps
the worst three-point shooter ever with
a career 30.5% shooting split from
Beyond The Ark Westbrook has jacked up
over 4,000 threes over his career easily
the worst accuracy of anyone with that
many attempts for reference he has
attempted more three-pointers in his
career than players like Mike Miller
Steve Nash or manu janob he's never been
an elite Defender despite his effort and
athleticism and his assist numbers Bell
the fact that he isn't really A Gifted
floor general or decision maker his
offenses with Durant were often
criticized for being too dependent on
Duel hero isolations and his time as a
solo artist saw Westbrook captaining
stagnant offenses that just watched him
dribble the shot clock out Harden's
style wasn't as visually mesmerizing as
Westbrook's was but that was almost by
Design Harden was the conductor and
focal point of Mor ball former Rockets
GM Daryl Mor's attempt to take the
Moneyball analytical revolution of
baseball and apply it to basketball the
simple idea was to take the most
efficient shots possible as often as
possible namely free throw throws layups
and threes and I don't think you could
design a player better suited for that
system than James Harden he was the
Cornerstone of one of the most effective
offenses in the league year in and year
out in the eight full seasons he spent
as a rocket Houston led the NBA in
three-pointers six times and were one of
the top four scoring offenses six times
which nobody wants to talk about because
the rocket style all those years was
kind of boring possessions usually ended
one of four way Harden would free
himself from his Defender with a nasty
crossover or a step back he would break
down Defenders with his dribble and dart
to the rim he would penetrate and kick
it to the corner for a three or he would
draw a foul and that's about it while
some purists derided Westbrook for his
all will no smarts style others would
look at harden and the rockets and decry
that the soul had been taken out of the
game reduced to an equation to be solved
which may be true but it discounts
Harden's ability to actually solve the
equation the offense went almost
entirely through him but it worked
because he was an all-time great scorer
with a bottomless bag of tricks and a
passing ability and Court Vision that
made him a virtually Unstoppable slash
and kick threat of course on the other
end of the floor Harden goes down almost
just as memorably as one of the worst
Defenders of his era you could also ding
the fact that he was so proficient
because he was in the perfect spot the
front office had the right philosophy he
played in the right system he had the
right coach and and he benefited from a
roster built entirely around his
strengths in other situations where he
hasn't had the fortune of having an
entire team built around him he
struggled to find the same success and
adjust his play to those around him he
only succeeds when he is the system if
you will so how about the numbers and
awards their basketball resumés the
regular season averages are shockingly
similar with a slight Advantage going to
Westbrook in rebounds assists and steals
he averages more points rebounds assists
and steals in the playoffs though but
obviously the statistic that matters for
Westbrook is the triple double double
digigit figures in three statistical
categories he is the all-time leader in
the statistic and likely will be for
decades he averaged the feat in 2017 and
then did it again in 2018 and in 2019 oh
and in 2021 too so he did it for three
straight years and again in the League's
first season postco he did it so much
that it probably started devaluing the
triple what used to be a pretty clear
sign of a player having a sensational
all-around game became a neat little
footnote stat which just goes to show
how absurd his stats are Russell
oversaturated the triple double stat so
much that it has lost some of its
significance nobody can really touch
that Harden comes close though like I
said their all-around statistics are
pretty similar but Advanced statistics
are going to favor hardened by a mile
which you could have guessed but his
most impressive stat well I think
there's two the first has to do with the
fact that although he might not be quite
as prolific as Westbrook in putting up
triple doubles when Harden does it he
does it big there have been 15 50o
triple doubles in NBA history at the
time of this recording Harden has
registered five of them including the
first 60o triple double in NBA history
the second stat 36.1 points per game in
2019 here's the list of players who have
ever topped 36 points for a season Willl
Chamberlain Michael Jordan James Harden
that's the list it was the highest
scoring clip since Michael Jordan's 87
campaign and the seventh highest scoring
average for a single season in NBA
history I don't know if I need to say
more the dude was a Dynamo and the two
have the awards and accomplishments to
match their talents they both went to
the finals in 2012 but Harden has some
pretty clear advantages here more First
Team all NBA appearances better MVP
finishes and he can say he took two
teams to the Conference Finals as the
best player they did both also win an
MVP award Westbrook won his first in
2017 the year after Kevin Durant left
for the Warriors and I think it's safe
to say that Russell's feelings were
pretty straightforward it was a breakup
he probably felt like he'd been dumped
and wanted to show exactly what he was
capable of so he erupted into a
supernova and averaged a triple double
for the first time in 55 years he led
the league in scoring broke the single
season record for triple doubles and
recorded the highest usage rate for a
season in history despite his
accomplishments the Thunders record was
anything but inspiring they won 47 games
and made the playoffs as the sixth seed
Westbrook became the first player to win
the MVP award on a team under 50 wins
since Moses Malone in 1982 those opposed
to Westbrook's MVP in 2017 argue that he
monopolized the ball chased stats more
than anyone cares to admit failed to
make his team better and was rewarded
because of the story and you know they
weren't exactly eating their words when
the Thunder lost in the first round to
the Rockets four games to one which
opened the door for Harden to take home
the MVP the next year in 2018 Harden
opened up his throttle in 18 and took
his game to an even higher level he led
the league in scoring finished third in
assists dropped that 60-point triple
double and had the first back-to-back 50
Burgers since 07 Kobe the Rockets
finished the season with 65 wins a
league back and franchise record but of
course it wouldn't be a vintage James
Harden year if there wasn't a vintage
collapse in the playoffs the rocket
season ended in the Western Conference
Finals in game seven against the
warriors with a 3-2 lead the Rockets had
had chances in game six and game seven
to send Golden State home and punch
their ticket to the finals they blew a
17-point lead in game six and a 15-point
lead in game seven that seventh game is
remembered as the game in which the Rock
Rockets shot Seven of 44 from Beyond The
Ark including a stretch of 27
consecutive missed threes now that is
the James Harden experience and that's
the last thing to look at are these guys
winning players do they make teams and
teammates better well in the case of
James Harden he makes teams better his
style is more conducive to winning than
Westbrooks is it's true Harden has won
seven playoff series as the best player
on his team Westbrook has won zero you
can blame the Meltdown in 2018 against
the warriors on Chris Paul's injured
hammy you can say that Harden and his
team gave the curry Durant Warriors
everything they could handle and you
would be right but I don't know how you
get around the fact that James Harden
will be remembered as a quitter and as
the choke artist of his generation it
would have to be a video in itself to go
in depth on all of Harden's playoff
disappointments but you can just rattle
them off 2015 against the Warriors 2017
against the Spurs 2018 against the
Warriors 2023 against the Celtics and so
on he quit on the rockets and gained a
ton of weight after the bubble stinking
up the joint and demanding a trade he
got his wish and became part of a
superbly dysfunctional core with the
Nets he was never happy started milking
injuries and was traded again after just
one season with the franchise with the
Sixers he imploded in the playoffs
started publicly deriding the
Philadelphia GM one Mr Daryl Mory
demanded a trade after one season and
got sent to the Clippers James Harden's
two most elite skills might be his
ability to draw fouls and quitting but
it's not like Russell Westbrook has a
bevy of awesome playoff moments to
counter with during his years with
Durant the Thunder were fixtures in the
playoffs and perennial contenders but it
always felt like Westbrook was the one
holding them back he never knew how to
pick his spots and bring a balance to
the offense and sure some of that blame
goes to Durant too but Russell's the
point guard isn't he shouldn't he be the
one helping fix the problems and after
Durant left his career has been
practically devoid of meaningful playoff
moments I mean what's the best playoff
game he's ever played even with ktie
doesn't it say something that you
probably have to struggle to think of
one during his best years as an
individual the Thunder were first round
exits every year I think the Crux of the
argument comes down to what question
we're asking are we asking who the
better player is who's the guy that
ranked higher on the ladder pyramid
hierarchy of alltime greats then the
answer is Harden without question he had
more success as the best player on his
team than Westbrook did and was the one
beating Westbrook out for all those
first team all League spots but who
would you want on your team sure Harden
could very possibly make your team a
contender but he has proven time and
again that the most likely outcome is
not a championship it's a flameout after
which he'll pass the blame around quit
trying and leave he's done it at every
stop of his career these past few years
meanwhile for all of his faults the one
thing you know about Russell Westbrook
is that he is not going to quit on you
he is going to give you everything he
has his mentality might be detrimental
to team success but man the dude cares
and because of that I think in the
future he'll be regarded much more
warmly will be remembered much more
fondly than Harden sure he's shot his
team out of games more than most guys in
the league ever have but not because
he's vain or because he's selfish it's
because he honestly believes that he is
the best basketball player on the planet
and is capable of anything wouldn't you
rather go out with a guy who was
shooting rather than just standing there
letting the season Fall Apart I don't
know that's why I'm asking you and
however you feel there isn't a right
answer that's what makes these guys
special they're two of the greatest
players of all time they've done things
that will likely not be matched for
years and years to come if ever again
and their accomplishments are rivaled
only by their flaws there isn't a right
answer so who would you take